at the end there are two kinds of
entrepreneurs uh there are those that
come with the technology right
try to find a solution uh or a need for
this kind of technology
and those that are trying to find the
need and to develop a technology for
that specific need
i'm from the second
type
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders today i'm
with zohar al-achmi the chairman and ceo
of defense solutions before founding and
leading defense solutions he was the
founder and ceo of three startup
companies he also held vice president
and c-level positions at amdocs and the
eci telecom global and public
telecommunication enterprises while
managing multi-disciplinary large and
small-scale organizations zohar created
fast growth and profitable businesses
bringing innovative solutions and
services to the market he graduated
laude with the bsc from the technion
israel institute of technology
and a master's from toby university and
was a lecturer at both institutions
it's really great to have you here and
you know serial entrepreneur is i think
your you know your journey depicts that
statement uh working on a variety of
technologies from software based to
today drone defense and and looking at
the world in in various lenses and so
before we get specifically to defend and
what you're doing with drones and
looking at the world
a little bit in a futuristic way tell me
a little bit about yourself and and how
you think through your own
entrepreneurial spirit what has sort of
been the guiding north star for you as
you've been transitioning through the
different companies you've worked with
well tell you about myself so i grew
over here in israel
nothing special in that
i
joined the test neon and i was i had my
first degree over there bsc
and then i moved to tel aviv university
um
i did my uh second degree over there
and and then i started
my career
i started with big companies and then i
started with startups
um
was a member of the team that started
dsl technology
and from the started the
type of sas
for enterprises activity
um
i lived
most of my business life were in the us
at that time
i also had some time in uh asia-pac
region
i managed the original vice president of
them docs within asia
yes so i managed the region for end docs
um
bottom line i am a strange type of
creature where i started in the academy
and i moved to the business life and
that's what they do
incredible and and eventually
um you're getting into the drone space
was that you know um
natural thing was this something that
you've researched for a while how does
how does one get to
you know to transition to working in
something like defense solutions six
years ago
trust if you look at my career you'll
see that i never really did the same
thing right
so my first activity was dsl the second
one was sas for enterprises
software play
third one was
mobile advertisement
and this is the fourth one so
every time i'm just moving to a
different type of business different
type of technology
and this is really what i like
in what i do as an entrepreneur
um
how did i fund it so i think that um at
the end there are two kinds of
entrepreneurs uh there are those that
come with the technology right uh try to
find a solution uh or a need for this
kind of technology and those that are
trying to find the need and to develop a
technology for that specific need
i'm from the second
type
um so i was looking for a need
and the need i found is this type of
dealing with drones or actually
protecting ourselves from drones
um
so that's that's exactly
what i'm trying to do over here bottom
line uh the drone type of let's call it
society is a very important one it's
really the future of many of the things
that we are experiencing right now and
also will experience
uh going after and it's an important one
we try to do is uh bottom line uh
support the growth of this type of
society and
let's call it secure drone adoption
while providing innovation
uh technology to support it
wonderful so you know before we talk
about defense solutions specifically
take me a little bit thirty thousand
from the area because you know i have a
feeling that most people listening to
this and hearing about you know drone
technologies we're thinking about dji
we're thinking about you know the
consumer drone market that when i go on
a family trip i take it up to take
pictures of me
but what is happening with drone
technologies around the world and how is
this
going to
get integrated into society in really
meaningful ways
first each one of us will when we
speak about drones we have a different
picture
in the head
some of us see amazon bringing
stuff to our home with drones
some of us see pizza coming with that
and others are using that in different
malicious ways so bottom line it's a
very nice type of technology
but it's not just that if you look about
let's say 10 years ago
in order to acquire such a technology
you used to have to buy um
or invest 50 200 million dollars and
this kind of equipment
right now
for 1500
you can order yourself from amazon or
anyone else
a drone that really
can give you capabilities amazing
capabilities which allows you and my
kids
to buy these type of drones very
efficiently
right
successfully so that's really the nature
of that now connect to that a very
powerful cameras
4k camera that is coming pre-integrated
and you get yourself a very
sophisticated camera flying around here
and allows you to do that very easily
and quickly
i think that this is really
uh the big change so what you're talking
what you're talking about here is the
sort of the
the availability
of getting
really sophisticated and complicated
systems into the hands of consumers at
very cheap prices and what i'm hearing
from that is the this decentralization
of of these not yet weapons but perhaps
one day weapons or or or any tools that
can be then leveraged to
to to means that we don't want them to
be used that is a risk here that we have
to address that now we it's no longer
specific armies or specific groups that
we know are purchasing these in our
manufacturing these for high prices and
we can deal with them but you now have a
decentralization of these up in the air
and we don't have much control over it
right
that's that's correct
um
that's correct for sure
and some of that is coming from
malicious type of usage and some of the
i mean just from
inability of really the people that use
it to understand the danger
uh
that
and what really can happen if they use
it in the wrong way let's say
if you try to use these type of drones
and speak about kids right now next to
airports
and you try to take a very cool picture
of
any kind of plane taking off
that's dangerous
right okay so now that we understand a
little bit better the risks associated
with this
where is it actually meeting us so so we
talked about the idea that now people
have access to this technology but what
tangible narrative like
scenarios can we imagine happening
that would that a company like defense
solutions becomes extremely relevant in
the last few years what are we actually
defending against
i'll give you several scenarios and
examples i think that all of them are
ones that you can remember actually by
yourself what really happened so one as
i mentioned before airports
uh think about the get week
event uh around three and a half years
ago
where at the end get week and hit your
airports were shut down for nearly 72
hours because of that
so the impact uh on an airport is very
clear
and that's one example
another uh
if you think about all this let's call
it the vip locations
whether this is the buckingham palace
whether this is the white house whether
this is the
pm office
the japanese pm office prime minister
office
all of those
locations were locations where people
actually just landed drones
next to them or really on them if it's
the prime minister of japan in this case
um
none of them were actually terrorists
most of them
but bottom line this is a very important
place to protect yourself from as well
um
another one
prisons
drones right now are the most let's call
it popular in one way
on one hand and very easy
type of way to smuggle
narcotics mobile devices
any kind of elimination and
other type of equipment that you don't
want to be smuggled into prisons
um
sports events
and other let's call it crowd based
events at the end
you don't want a drone to fly over your
head when you watch
the super bowl
and that's one hand and you don't want
any kind of drone to take the ip rights
of
any one
organization that actually acquire these
ip rights
um
for for money
so bottom line over there it's not just
safety it's not just security it's also
ip rights
right
that makes a lot of sense but but take
me back to you know to 2016.
you're
realizing what's happening to the world
you're realizing the threats you're
realizing that the consumer
demands from the world are going to also
require us to have drones
in our everyday lives right and and they
are going
besides just the consumer entertainment
they are going to be playing a a an
important part in deliveries and in
maintenance and security and
and and and surveillance and
construction and pretty much everything
we can think of
where is defense solutions coming into
play in 2016 what is sort of the thesis
that you come in and say i want to
do this
when um when we started that we
evaluated all the different technologies
available in the market to deal with
runs
and what we found out is that uh
traditional type of technologies the one
that was developed
for detection and then mitigation of
uh let's call it mig and f16 and all of
these big aircrafts
is the one being utilized
uh against runs
now while these are great technologies
they were developed for something else
and they don't really fit to the really
current situations we are in
so on one hand if you want to try and
protect yourself from drones inside
manhattan
or if you want to protect the pope
you cannot use the radar over there
in order to identify these type of
drones
these type of tools would really develop
for something else
and and the rather is not a solution for
that and that's goes for detection
um
and if you'll speak about or if you try
to understand the mitigation part of
that
at the end there are two types of
mitigation available back then and even
today until we came
and that were kinetic solutions
meaning everything that flies very fast
in the air and make a big or a small
boom at the end
depending on what you use over there
and the jammers
any kind of gps jammers wifi jammers
communication jammers gps poofers
technologies which bottom line the
collateral damage of those is huge
and
uh
and if you try to use any of those in
any of the scenarios i mentioned before
what you find yourself in this is in a
situation that this is really
um not a viable solution you cannot fire
any kind of missile above manhattan you
cannot try to protect the pope and this
is a real case that uh
we just released about three months ago
we saved the pope
in a real event you cannot fire a
missile over there
and on the other hand you cannot really
jam if you're going to jam you're going
to have an impact on all the
communication in the
in that type of environment
so
we
came with the understanding that we need
to develop something else
that will be will enable
all of these type of law enforcement and
people that trying to protect
um
and to have a secure type of environment
for us
to use in this kind of locations and
that's what we did so we developed a
technology which enables to
identify
track and locate these type of drones
using the communications these type of
drones are having
and we take control and i really mean we
take control over these
drones only the hostile ones with no
really no
any kind of uh collateral damage at all
so we have no impact on any of the other
drones flying over there or other
communications running over there and of
course it is not kinetic
so bottom line
it's really safe solution to control
this type of problem
i usually like to say that we take a
drone incident
and we verify that it's not going to
become an incident at all so the case is
a classic example um it was released
only three months after the event nobody
actually knew that we were very close to
have a drone incident over there
um and nothing happened
well i think that's the that's the best
case scenario of people not realizing
that they were close to an event that's
real that's when you know that you that
you've actually mitigated it in the in
the best way possible how do you you
know from from a technological and
innovative perspective
you know this this cat and mouse game of
new technologies arising for drones and
then you're on the defensive side
how do you as the company make sure that
you're constantly at the forefront of
the technology that you're constantly
you know you're you're understanding the
market you understand what they're what
are the different opportunities and
you're able to create solutions that
will defend against the most cutting
edge technologies what is it about you
know the way that you're running defense
that allows for that to happen
maybe before i really answer your
question let me go a step backward
the understanding
that this is a cat and mouse game is a
very important one
many
other type of solutions are the ones
that you give to the customer
and that's the solution from today till
the rest of the life of that specific
equipment
this is not the case or that's not a
viable type of solution in uh in the
drones type of world exactly because of
the reason you mentioned
so you must have this kind of ability to
upgrade and update the the product and
the offering
all the time
i think that the best analogy for that
is your antivirus on your computer we
need to have this antivirus
updated all the time
to deal with the new type of viruses
that we have
all the time this is exactly what we do
it's not a nice to have type of uh
capability now
what we did was to develop a methodology
to do exactly that
we developed an internal methodology to
deal with new type of
viruses sorry drones
that are coming to the market
every time
and we will verify that we just release
updates and we verify that we deal with
the most advanced type of threats
and
allow our customers to use those and
protect
their cells from these type of threats
incredible now in terms of company
culture
and how you're
creating a culture of continuous
curiosity innovation
um and and advancement what what do you
notice there on a leadership side
that allows for a company to to have
that mentality constantly innovating
constantly learning and researching
i think it's a mix
first
um call it make it happen
we always
uh
can deal with everything
uh this is part of the dna of the
company there isn't such a word like no
we can't
the only question is how do we do it
um
so that's part of the dna that started
uh
from day one
and that's what we have right now
um
and
innovation bottom line
really achieves the impossible
and we try to think about all of these
kind of problems
in an innovative way
to find an innovative technology to deal
with that um that's
i believe the two key type of elements
to deal with what you just asked me
about
incredible and uh i think that it's a
it's it's so
amazing you know hearing about you know
the way that you are first of all you
know personal career and how you've
you've done different things you know
across the board but all of them are
deeply curious about them advancements
of technologies and looking to be the
forefront of what's happening to us
today and how technology is shaping you
know really humanity in civilization and
of course with with defense solutions
the way that six years ago you were
looking at at drones and understanding
yes it's great that we can now purchase
you know 200 300 drones on amazon or
1500 to get you know the most high-end
drones that just 10 years ago maybe
would would cost dozens of thousand
dollars for militaries and and and
you're saying there's there's a gap here
with the way that we are going to be
experiencing a new level of threats a
new cat and mouse game that that you're
going to be at the forefront of
and and it's just amazing and it's a
huge pride for the israeli ecosystem and
i really appreciate you taking your time
to come and chat with me and best of
luck with defense solutions and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you
[Music]